it feels like the right time for a look
back at the Captain Planet cartoon after
we watching it through the jaded eyes of
adulthood we're here to bring you or the
strange hanging plot threads surprising
facts and head-scratching moments that
we completely breezed past as children
when Yuri watch Captain Planet as an
adult you'll be startled how many times
you'll find yourself saying I know that
voice that's because many of the biggest
South of the early 90s lend their voices
to this animated series what makes this
even more delightful is that most of the
star power was concentrated in the
villains so these normally respectable
actors really get a chance to have some
fun as they portrayed a delightfully
hammy eco-villains that opposed the
planeteers meg Ryan played the
megalomaniacal scientist dr. blight and
her talking computer mal was played by
Tim Curry throwing most of his
appearances the oil baron hoggish
greedly was voiced by Ed Asner while his
sidekick irregular was brought to life
by John Ratzenberger Martin Sheen played
sliced sludge James Coburn played loot
and plunder and the evil rat boots and
vermin Erskine was played by Jeff
Goldblum
Ebru
perhaps strangest of all the evil
spirits arm was played by the Rockstar
sting there are fewer household names
among the ranks of the heroes as most of
the planeteers were played by veteran
voice actors rather than live-action
a-listers but there were two notable
bits of Sun casting among the good guys
that seems mentor Gaia the spirits of
the earth was played by Whoopi Goldberg
[Music]
now in four planets years
and kwame the way order of the earth
ring was played by levar burton yes
Kwame it is in the first episode of
Captain Planet we meet the villainous
hoggish greedly an amoral oil baron who
starts legally drilling in a wildlife
sanctuary unconcerned with the massive
damages operation is doing to the local
wildlife it's a surprisingly realistic
motivation for an antagonist that's
nonetheless clearly evil and it makes
crudely and easily understandable
villain for a young audience
everybody loves seals however in most
subsequent episodes far less work is put
into coming up with three-dimensional
villains whose plans can survive even
the most cursory of examinations often
times the villains seem to be polluting
for its own sake if else actually
gaining anything from it favor in
stinson the episode deadly ransom dr.
blight kidnaps Captain Planet as part of
a plan that was seemingly result in our
own demise as well I'm going to learn
the secret of your power and then use it
to destroy the earth some villains do
better than others in this regard looten
plunder for instance is always clearly
motivated by money
the most consistently nonsensical
villain of the bunch is definitely
verminous scum he wants to spread
disease cause acid rain and transform
everyone in the world into mutant rats
like himself you know just because
that's so well and good if you're just
making a dumb kids cartoon but Captain
Planet is ostensibly trying to teach
kids about environmentalism it's not
exactly clear what we are well DeVos
verminous scum is supposed to represent
let's face it when you played Captain
Planet with your friends as kids nobody
wanted to be Marty DS summons tsunamis
wheeler is a human flamethrower Marty
can talk to animals to a child Marty's
ill-defined power of heart definitely
seems like the weakest of the five
however we watching through adult eyes
you realize that Marty might actually
have the scary a superpower of all Minds
control into futures wheeler travels to
a dark alternate timeline in which the
planet tears fail to stop humanity from
destroying the environment in this
reality the rainforests have been
destroyed most animo
extinct and New York City is underwater
Marty has also fallen on hard times
becoming a homeless beggar and
interestingly this version of Marty uses
his powers in a way that we've never
seen present-day Marty use them before
convincing rich people to donate to poor
people like himself this is still
clearly a fairly benign use of his
powers but it opens up a whole can of
worms about just what the limits of
Marty's powers actually are let's just
put it this way if we ever get that
gritty Captain Planet reboot that
absolutely no one is asking for we could
see a world in which the littlest planet
Eire goes dark a mind-controlling
supervillain in the vein of killgrave
from jessica jones you'd like to invite
me in absolutely
good thing marty is such a pure cinnamon
roll of a human being and we never have
to learn the answers to these kinds of
questions perhaps the most surprising
thing that you'll feel when you watch
Captain Planet as an adult is a profound
sense of sadness despite all the
warnings it gave us about issues like
deforestation extinction and climate
change
we still haven't really solved any of
these issues Captain Planet and the
Planeteers is often extremely optimistic
in terms of how simple it is to solve
the problems our threat in our world on
one hand it can be refreshing in our
increasingly complicated and cynical age
to personify all the world's
environmental issues as a single
cackling villain and then watch a flying
blue man with a mullet punched a villain
in the face on the other hand given how
impossible it seems for the world to
muster up the willpower to solve even
the most basic of problems it's also
completely understandable that this
simplistic outlook might strike you now
as hopelessly naive to the point of
being useless but despite our humph
aesthetic aget nowadays our world could
stand to have more cartoons like this
one Captain Planet and the Planeteers
was undeniably brave and decades later
it generally landed on the right side of
history that being said we watching this
series with adult eyes it's difficult to
not always feel at least a little tinge
of bitter sweetness it just goes to show
that once you grow up you can't really
go back to seeing anything from your
childhood how you did before check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
you